de
tamamladık artık
Merhabalar söylediği gibi adamın peşin
olgun ve bu konuşmanın başlığı Aslında
kariyer planlaması fakat birçok şey
olabilirdi başlamadan önce onu söylemek
istiyorum sosyal medya ve kadın
olabilirdi üniversitenin zorlukları
olabilirdim motive edici işte yaparsın
edersin gibi şeyler olabilirdi Fakat ben
kariyer planlaması seçtim çünkü bir
şekilde çalışarak ve çabalayarak bir
kariyer elde ettim ancak bir motivasyon
konuşmacısı değilim Ne yazık ki size
böyle gaza getirecek harika aynı
toplarım yok küçük kıza hikayelerim yok
yaparsın edersin Evet ben bu sınıf
dedirte bileceğim özlü sözlerim yok
Sadece ben Pelin olgun olarak
deneyimlerim var ve o deneyimleri
sizlere aktarmak istedim bu konuşma
mesela vesilesiyle çünkü Allah
herkesin deneyimi nasıl ki kendi Neyse
benimki de öyle oldu size diğer
başlıkları altında Şu an bir konuşma
yapmak isteseydim büyük ihtimalle ne
demek istediğimi tam olarak anlamaya
bilirsiniz Çünkü benimle aynısı da yüzme
diniz benimle aynı denize girmediniz ve
benimle aynı ayakkabıyı giymediğiniz
için doğal olarak söyleyeceğim Her şey
havada kalacaktır Ama şu an Sizler
özellikle lise öğrencileri olarak bence
çok önemli Bir dönüm noktasında sınız
bize insanın hayatında birçok dönüm
noktası vardır ama en önemlisi Bence
liseden sonra ki karşımıza çıkan dönüm
noktası Çünkü korkunç bir belirsizlik
var orada ve o belirsizlikle sene bugün
mesaj sınava girdiyseniz seneye bugün
nerede olacağım seneye bugün hangi
şehirde olacağım işte acaba hayatım
nasıl olacak sevdiğim bir Bölümü
okuyacağım veya kariyerimi tam olarak ne
yapmak istiyorum bilemiyorum diye
düşüneceksiniz Bence en zor olan kısım
bu ekran bul sonrası bir şekilde gidiyor
Ben de bu yollardan geçtim ve o yüzden
deneyimlerimi aktarmak istedim sizlere
Bu sayede belki motive olmayacaksınız
Ama şunu diyebilirsiniz ya Pelin olgun
yaptıysa ben de yaparım Aynı yolda
gitmeniz gerekmiyor Tabii ki Hadi
buradan mezun olduktan sonra hepimiz
youtuber olalım demeyeceğim zaten fen
lisesi'de okuyorsunuz ve bence çok zeki
insanlarsınız O yüzden youtuber olmaktan
ziyade çok çok çok daha iyi meslekler de
çalışabilirsiniz ancak En azından
anlattığım şeyler size belki işte Pelin
yaptıysa biz de yaparız dedi çeker Çünkü
çok normal bir insanım aslında normal
benim hayatım için inanılmaz önemli bir
kelime iyi olsun istemiyorum kötü olsun
istemiyorum Benim için en önemli şey
normal normal lise İyidir daha iyisi
olmasa da olur kendi normal hayatımı
anlatacağım O yüzden şöyle güzel ve her
söylemeden önce biraz kısaca
bahsettiğimiz benden ama ben de daha
detaylı En azından biraz bir
detaylandırılmış dedim İzmir'de doğdum
ve annem babam çalıştığı için beni ilk
önce İzmir'de Tepecik'te bir Göçmen
Mahallesinde Anneannem büyüktü Aynı
zamanda da babaannem anneanne babaanne
tarafından büyütüldü çocukluk yıllarında
ve ilk çocukluğumu Tepecik'te geçirdim o
zamanlar
sinek arabaları vardı onun arkasından
koşarak apartmanların anne Kimse verdik
oyun oynardık komşuculuk vardı Tepecik O
şimdi bildiğimiz İzmir'in Tepeci değil
açıkçası
ardından İzmir'in Selçuk ilçesinde bu
sefer Köy gibi adlandırılabilecek o
zamanlar biraz daha köylüköy gibi
adlandırabileceğimiz bir yerde yanımızda
ahırın olduğu bir evde yanardağ
bakıcılar tarafından büyütüyorum yine
annem ve babam çalıştığı için ve bakıcı
larımız Biz Tabiri caizse köylü insanlar
yani şimdi bana baktı Ya aslında ya bu
kadın Entel Dantel işte yok Efendim
kitaplardır sinemada falandı filandı
böyle yüksek yüksek konuşuyor diye ön
yargılı davranan bilecek insanların
olabileceği ortamda Aslında bakarsanız
ben genelde köylüler tarafından
büyütüldü ve iyi ki de öyle bir
üzülmüşüm çünkü hem Entel Dantel olan
ailemin ortamını gördüm hem de akşam
olur Entel Dantel bir ortamımız oluyordu
gündüz oluyordu bakıcımız geliyor ve ya
ben ona gidiyordum tam bir köylü
yaşamını görüyordum işte kocakarı
ilaçları getiriliyordu bozuk Türkçeler
İzmir şivesi ve saf sevgi saf köylü
sevgisini gördüm Aslında iki de öyle
olmuş çünkü bu zamanlara beni getiren
sizin beni tanımamıza vesile olan
YouTube'daki başarı diye adlandırılan
belki başkalarına göre değildir fakat
kendime göre bir başarı başarıyı elde
etmenin en büyük amacı da en büyük
vesilesi de gözlem bir şey mi oldu bu
gözlem yeteneğini de sanıyorum her türlü
insanlar küçük yaştan beri muhatap
olarak nokta bulmak kötü tutunamazsın
lütfen sizin kulağınızda Ama gerçekten
onlarla vakit geçirerek öğrendim İşte
adabı öğrendim bu vesileyle Kime nasıl
konuşabileceğim İşte ustayla da
konuşabiliyorum fakat biz üniversitenin
profesörü ile Doçent ile de
konuşabiliyorum bu bana çok şey kattı
böyle kültür farklı kültürün içinde
bilmek Dediğim gibi bana gözlem
yeteneğine inanılmaz katkıda sağladı ve
ardından Selçuk hikayesi bitip
Kuşadası'nda yerleştik apayrı bir yere
Selçuk buradaydı Kuşadası buralarda daha
farklı Belki daha lüks diyebileceğimiz
daha rahat diyebileceğimiz bir hayata
devrilmişti hayatımız Ve ortaokullar
lisenin bir kısmına Kuşadası'nda okudum
güzel dönemlerde tatlı daha farklı
deneyimleri o dönemde burada gözlem
yeteneğini Tabii ki çok geliştirecek bir
çok şey yaşadım fakat sonra işler ters
gitti ve ben ilk çocukluk yıllarımı
yaşadığım tpc geri döndüm ergenlik
çağında en asabi olacağım en anarşist
olacağım zamanlarda belki de benim için
çok zordu tpc dönmek Çünkü artık eski
Tepecik değildi müşteri sokaklarda
kilimlerde oynadığımız vesaire işleri
sinek arabaların arkasından koşturduğu
muz kapıları kilitleme dediğimiz Tepecik
yok ve apayrı bir yerdi korkarak sokağa
çıkıyorduk kıyafetlerimi değişmek
zorunda kalmıştı ve bu şekilde
adaptasyonu ne kadar zor ama yok kadar
da gerekli olduğunu öğrendim sanıyorum
Hayatımda iyi ki de öyle olmuş yine
birçok şeye kolay adapte olmayı bu
vesileyle öğrendim ve İzmir'de övgü
terzibaşıoğlu Anadolu Lisesi'nden mezun
oldum en son fakat
bu ev genelde bana yapamazsın dediler
çok akıllı bir öğrenci değilim açıkçası
O yüzden diyorum yani siz şimdi beni
dinlediğiniz de Pelin yaptıysa biz de
yaparız demişsiniz çünkü Bence Sizler
benim o yaşta olduğundan çok daha zeki
insanlarsınız Dur ben Lisesi'nde
okuyorsunuz yani ve matematiğin bile çok
kötüydüm ve mesela üniversite sınavına
girmeden önce lise sınavında bizim
Kuşadası'nda sitede oturan
arkadaşlarımız genelde yaşı tık ve
Ailelerimiz annelerimiz özellikle
günlerde bir sınava gireceğim zaman
kimin kazanacağını kazanacağı üzerine
iddiada bulunuldu ve yani Kimse benim
üzerime oynamaz the Pelin Çünkü akıllı
bir çocuk değildir ve büyük ihtimalle
sınavda Yapı umursamaz dır falan
derlerdi birçok kişiyle siteden birçok
arkadaşımın aynı sınava girmek zorunda
kaldım ne yazık ki çok fazla
karşılaştırdım onlarla ve şans eseri
midir artık Bilmiyorum belki Hırsızı
değilim Fakat Sakin bir insan ve hırslı
olmayıp sakin olmanın getirdiği Bir
güzellikle sınavda çok iyi bir puan
aldım ve neredeyse bütün arkadaşlarımıza
sitedeki herkesten daha iyi bilgisayar
Anadolu Lisesi'ne yerleşti
mama ilk yapamazsın mı burada almıştım
yani Pelin Anadolu Lisesi olmaz ya biz
onu düz liseye gönderelim dediler Ne var
ki düz lisede diyebilirsiniz ama bir
kısıtlama oluyor en azından neden
Anadolu Lisesi olması gelin olarak
güzel oldu En azından bir şaşırttım
insanları map elinde yapabiliyor Muş
Belki dediler Sonra üniversite sınavı
zamanı geldi ve
yabancı dil okuduğum lisede ve
üniversitede Ne istediğimi bilmiyordum
Fakat ne istemediğimi çok iyi biliyordum
Bence en önemli şey insanın ne
istediğini Çünkü isteyeceğiniz zaman
önünüzde Sonsuz derya var deniz var her
şeyi isteyebilirsin şu an uzaya çıkmak
da isteyebilirsiniz mesela mümkün olmasa
da veya Ya bilmiyorum denizin altında
beş saat Nefes almadan durmayı da
isteyebilirsin istemenin sınır yok fakat
istememenin sınırları çok belli ve ben o
sınırları çok güzel çizmiştim şunu
istemiyorum Evet İngilizce okuyorum
fakat tam olarak ingilizce bir şeyler
yapmak istemiyorum edebiyatı çok
seviyorum yazmayı çok seviyorum Ne
yapabilirim araştırdığımda
karşılaştırmalı edebiyat bölümünü buldum
ve benim için tek tercih artık orası ydı
tek bir üniversitede Tek Bir bölüm
olarak vardı o zamanlar şimdilerde 9
Eylül'de açıldı tek tercih yaptım
üniversite sınavında iki gün üst üste
sınava giriyorsunuz o zaman Benim
zamanımda işte ilk önce üniversite
yerleştirme sınavı sonra yabancı dil
sınavı olarak ilk sınava girerken Babam
bana dedi ki Senden adam olmaz Sen boş
ver sınava girme Yani ben o yapamazsın
aldım ama panik olmadım üzülmedim
sıkılmadım Sakin bir şekilde sınav bu ve
sana Mega Zindanda iyi geçmişti tam bir
sonuçlar gelinceye kadar biraz Allah
kulaklı ama sonra sınavına çık lan
sonuçların açıklandığı gün önceden
puanımız açıklanıyordu ardından tercih
yapıyorduk şu an sistemi bilmiyorum
açıkçası bakar puanım açıklandığında
istediğim yeri ve yarım tutabileceğini
görmüştüm tek Tercih yapmış ne demiş mi
diye karşılaştırmalı edebiyat olacak ya
da olmayacak fakat bir daha Sınava da
girmeye gerçekten tahammülüm yok Belki
de bir şekilde iş hayatına atılırım
telefon açtım Babama dedim ki baba böyle
böyle bir şey oldu ani puanla çıkan
Sanırım benim istediğim bölüm tutuyor ve
babam bana şey dedi gerçekten tuttuğumda
beni ara benim
yine üzülmedim Bu arada Çünkü sanıyorum
böyle bir şey var yani Eskiler özellikle
yapamazsın demeyi daha kolay buluyorlar
fakat yapmak daha zor oluyor Neyse ki o
ve bu dediğim gibi tek tercih yaptım ve
yerleştirdim güzeldir puanla yerleştim
üniversiteye be sonra hayatımın en güzel
dönemi başladı
üniversite hayatı gerçekten yani çoğunuz
Zaten lise öğrencisi Siz burada ve
hepinizin amacı büyük ihtimalle
üniversite isterseniz okumaya
alabilirsiniz Kesinlikle böyle bir
zorunluluk olduğunu düşünmüyorum fakat
Yollar ya üniversite okumayanlar Hayat
Üniversitesi'nden mezun oldum ben bir
bak hiç ona katılmıyorum çünkü asıl
Hayat üniversitesi gerçekten
üniversiteye başladığımızda başlıyor
orada çok farklı insanlarla muhatap
olmak zorunda kalıyorsunuz ev belki
sokakta yanından geçtiğinizde
bakmayacağımız hiç arkadaşınız bile
olmayacak kişilerle aynısını
paylaşıyorsunuz Bu da insana aynı nasıl
ki bana küçüklüğünde bu gözlem
yeteneğini katan farklı farklı bu ile
birlikte olmaya getirdiyse varsa
öğrencisi öğrencisine değer o zamana
kadar böyle bir fırsatı Olmadıysa böyle
bir güzellik katıyor
ve çok severek okudum Bu arada bölümü
tek tercih sevmeme gibi bir şansım yoktu
ama Hem kitap okumak olsun hem yazmak
olsun herşeyiyle Gerçekten böyle mi çok
sevdim ve çok harika bir beş sene
geçirdim bu beş sene değil de çok fazla
şey öğrendim kesinlikle ders anlamında
değil kesinlikle edebiyat anlamında veya
herhangi bir bilgi anlamında değil bak
at insanlarla iletişimi öğrendim tek
başına yaşamayı öğrendim fatura ödemeyi
öğrendim hayatımda hiç fatura ödenmemiş
kira ödemeyi Eğer maaş alacaksınız bir
yerden bu ay sonu ne kadar zor geldiğini
fakat kira ödeyeceksiniz O aysonun hemen
geldiğini öğrendim ve gerçekten
bugünlere gelmemde Evet belki bu
anlattığım şeyler somut olay Evet şu an
YouTube'da programlar yapıyor Fakat ne
anlatıyor bu kadın haline ne diyor ne
demek istiyormuş bu araştırmadım
diyebileceğiniz şeyler olabilir ama tam
olarak benim böyle gözlem yapma Biraz
daha sakin olup oturmama uzaktan bakmama
izleme vesile olacak şeyler oldu oldu
üniversiteden mezun olduk bir şekilde
Çünkü
kapattıktan sonra bir şekilde soruda
geliyor açıkçası Son pişmanlık
yaşamadığımı yaşadım Atıyorum Hiç biraz
daha uzat Saydım Çünkü insan
üniversitedeyken birden mezun olmak
istiyor ve iş hayatına atılmak istiyor
ama iş hayatına atıldığında da keşke
üniversite devam etseydim bir Çünkü
üniversitedeyken teknik sorumluluğumuz
var sınavlara çalışıp o sınavlardan
geçmek Hatta Hayatınız boyunca Eğer
normal bir hayatımız varsa gerçekten çok
da ekstrem şeyler yaşayabilirsiniz
ailevi sorunlar olabilir sağlık ama
normal bir hayatımız varsa üniversiteye
kadar tek bir sorumluluğumuz oluyor ders
çalışmak ve sınavları geçmek bir sokak
mezun olduktan sonra her şey Allah
kabuluk oluyor tam olarak ne hep
oluşturacağınız nereye işte başvuru
yapacağınızı Ne iş yapacağınızı
karşılaştırmalarda Batman kolay bir
bölüm değildi ve oradan mezun olduğunda
komperatif diye bir bölge iş kolu yok
yani ne yapacağınızı bilemiyorsunuz ama
neyse ki güzel bir şekilde mezun oldu
girdim kadar iyi bir puanla mezun
olmadım ama güzeldi yine Belin olarak
fena değil normal puanlamalar ve
ardından İstanbul'a yerleştim hemen taşı
toprağı altındır dedikleri
oyalandım yere yerleşmiş oldum Taşı
toprağı kalmıştı Ben geldiğimde sadece
Altın bulamadık pek fazla ama sonuç
olarak şans eseri haber merkezlerinde
çalışmaya başladım Ne de olsa bu kız
yazı yazıyor dediler ve bana editörlük
verdiler ardından muhabirlik yaptım işte
söylediği gibi sonra spikerliğe kadar
uzandı bu ve ve işte burada konuşma şey
ola bu
kariyer hayatında kadın olmanın zorluğu
Olabilir çünkü bazı sektörlerde kadın
olduğumuzda Gerçekten sizi ciddiye
almıyorlar ve tam olarak ne yapmamız
gerektiğini sizde bilmiyorsunuz Çünkü o
zamana kadar size normal davranmış
oluyor ama iş zamanı gelince zaman işe
gelince
kadın olmanın verdiği dezavantajlarına
yazık Çok fazla yaşadım İzmir litreyle
İstanbul'da
haber merkezlerinde çalışmanın zorluğunu
gerçekten çok fazla yaşadım yine
yapamazsın lar oldu önceden annemden
aldığım yapamazsın lar sonradan Baba'dan
aldım yapmasınlar ardından elin oğlu
dediğimiz patronlardan ev kadını dediğim
senin kız dediğimiz patronlardan geldi
ve Neyse ki yaptım Yine sakin kalarak ve
çabalayarak yaptım Ancak bir yer sor bir
yerden sonra haber merkezi maceram da
saçma bir şekilde bitti Ne yazık ki
Sen benimle yapamamış çünkü en son ve
şans eseri YouTube başladı artık
başladıktan sonraki halinde yani
anlatmayı uzun Zaten sizler biliyorsunuz
böyleydi benim Pelin olgun olarak bu A
bu zamana gelmem yani Çok da detaylı
anlatmadım açıkçası ama burada demek
istediğim şey şu yapamazsın ları çok
duydum olmazları çok duydum ve adına
bana her şey çok zor geldi O an yaşarken
o kadar çok zor geldi ki şu an size
belki 20 dakika oldu konuşmaya başladı
20 dakika da pıtır pıtır pıtır anlattım
Çünkü aslında o kadar kolaymış yani
adapte olmak çok önemli bazı şeylere
kötü şeyi de almak onu da bir göğsünde
yumuşatmak ve ondan sonra gerekiyorsa
buraya atmak çok önemli ama o göğüste
yumuşatmanın da olmuyor işte bunu
yapmayı öğrendim Sizler çok gençsiniz
hepinizi çok özeniyorum belki sizlerin
yerinde olsam çok farklı şeyler yapardım
bu bambaşka yerlere gider diyorum
ama size söyleyebileceğim tek bir şey
var Sakin olmanız hayatımın hiçbir
şekilde sonu gelmiyor Ne olursa olsun
sonu gelmiyor sınava giriyorsun
kazanamıyor Sun Hayat Devam Ediyor işte
yapamazsın diyorlar yapmıyorsun çoğu
zaman da yapamıyorsun açıkçası ama yine
hayatın sonu gelmiyor O da yaptığında
çok güzel oluyor Siz olarak bir şeyler
yaptığınız zaman başkasının hakkını
yemediğiniz zaman
başkalarının hakkına girmediğiniz zaman
gerçekten çabalayıp yapamadığınız da
bile bunun tadı apayrı güzel olur Çünkü
en azından ben çabaladım diye
biliyorsunuz ben çok çabaladım biraz
şans da yüzüme güldü ama kimsenin
hakkını yemedim şimdiye kadar ve genç
İnsanlara çok yaşlı sayılmam açıkça
söyle genç insanlar diye konuşuyorum ama
sonuçta benden çok daha gençsiniz geniş
insanlara verebileceğim tavsiye
gerçekten bu kendinize inanmanız olacak
yapamazsın diyenler çok olur
yapamazsınız canınızı sıkmayın ama
yapamazsanız bir sonraki daha iyi
yaparsın öyle düşünüyorum açıkçası
bazen de yapmazsınız da var ki hayatının
sonu değil İnsanlar kolunu bacağını
kaybediyor ve hayatlarına devam ediyor
Bir sadece hedefimizden belki bir yıl
kaybetmiş oluyoruz belki iki yıl hadi
beş yıl kaybedilir hiçbir şey gerçekten
Biz o hedeften döndür emiyor ve
bu zamanlarda insanlar pes etmeye çok
yatkın oluyor yani en ufak bir kötülük
geldiğinde başımıza ya başına daha kötü
ne gelebilir ki diyebiliyoruz bunu demen
gerektiğini söyledi Çünkü başıma daha
kötü ne gelebilir ki dediğin an beynim
düşünmeye başlıyor daha kötü ne olabilir
Daha kötü olabilir Daha ve onu
kokladığımızda o daha kötü geliyor Şunu
demenizi istiyorum sizde ne Ama şu an
belki kötü bir şey yaşıyorum Fakat bunun
daha iyisi var onun daha iyisini
yapabilirim iyi bir şey yaşadığınızda da
yalan çok iyi bir şey yap yaşıyorum diye
sevinme nizi öneriyorum Çünkü bize
genelde duygularımızı bastırmak
öğretildiği için üzüldüğümüzde
sevindiğimizde de kendimiz bir
düzenlemeye çalışıyoruz ve bu sen belki
de bizim gelecekteki
gerçekleştireceğimiz şeyleride frenleme
mize neden oluyor bırakın aksın gitsin
hayatınız ve ve gerçekten daha iyisin ne
olabilir diye konuşun kendinize böyle
konuşalım Bu arada karakter olarak da
pratik bir insan olduğumu düşünüyorum
ama bu pratikliği de üşengeçliği ne
bağladım şimdiye kadar üşenir Seniz de
hiç bence sorun etme işini burada
Hocalar varsa kusura bakmayın hocalarım
Ama
öğrencilerin üşenme sine izin verdim
çünkü ben hep erteleyen hep düşene bir
insandım sınavları son dakikada çalış bu
makale yazılacaksa son dakikada yazardım
ve son dakikada yazdığım için beynim
oldu son dakikalarda hep daha pratik
çalışıp Hep başkalarının o düzlem
üzerinde düşündüğü şeyleri son pikte
yaşayıp daha çabuk adapte olmamı sağladı
bazı şeylere ve bu yüzden pratik
öğrendim sonuna kadar ertelediğim de bir
işi en çabuk nasıl yapabileceğimi
öğrendim Mesela biz No 3 gün boyunca da
çalışabilirim ama yedi saatte çalışıp
çok daha iyi puanlar aldığım oldu bunu
önerdiğim söylenemez ama ben böyle
yaptım sizin karakteriniz Belki buna
uygun değildir sakın örnek almayın
sadece kendinizi dinleyin ilk önce onun
dışında
yavaş bitirmek istiyorum aslında Çok da
konuşurum bıraksanız beni de
farklı şeylerden de bahsetmek istiyorum
sistemin sizi Zorlayacak mı söylemek
istiyorum Bu arada sistem al sistemi
veya ben sistemi değil a ilçesinde AB
ülkesinin sistemi değil otursun olmuş bu
marka fakat Bizler oturmuş insanlar
değildi hayatımız durmaksızın değişiyor
durmaksızın gelişiyor her şey değişiyor
ancak sistemler Bizim de işimiz kadar
değişmediği için
Sizler ile iki zamanımızda Bu sistemden
çok çekeceksiniz bizim annelerimiz
babalarımız da çekti bizim dedelerimiz
ninelerimiz de çekti Atatürk de çekti
ondan öncekiler de çekti ve sisteme
karşı gelmekten ziyade ona adapte olarak
belki de
bilmiyorum sistemi biraz daha
değiştirmeye çalışmamız gerekiyor diye
düşünüyorum Bu karşı gelmek değiştirme
karşı gelmek anlamında değil kesinlikle
Çünkü değişim her zaman iyi niyetli de
olabilir karşı geldiğinizde bazen ters
yapabiliyor ancak yılmayın Çünkü sistem
bu kabul edin sanırım konuşmamın genel
anlamı normallik ve kabul etmek üzerine
kurulan bir kariyer üzerine oldu ama ben
sadece böyleydim ve ayakta durmayı dene
ne demek istiyorum size Çünkü ne olursa
olsun denemezsen zaten bitmiş
oluyorsunuz ve denemek 100 de 50
şansınıza arttırıyor Belki de daha iyi
olur diyorum ben bunları yaparak Şu an
sizin benimle bizimle konuşmasını
istediğiniz kişi oldum Belin olgun oldum
çok büyük bir şey olduğunu düşünmüyorum
ama umuyorum size Gerçekten birazcık
motive edici şeyler söylemişim de belki
birazcık ufkunuzu açacak şeyler
söylemişimdir Eğer beni YouTube'da görüp
konuşmamı sevdiyseniz yazdığı metinleri
sevdiyseniz beni sevdiyseniz birazcık
dikkate almanızı ve hayatın normal
akışına bırakmanızı rica edeceğim sizden
üniversite hayatımdan bahsetmiştim Ama
konuşmayı da açıkçası şöyle bitirmek
istiyorum üniversite hayatımın son
döneminin son dersinde bir hocamız bana
not yazdırmıştı ve bütün sınıfa
yazdırmıştı Bu arada onu da hala
saklarım Hatta bakıyorum şimdi Cami
yatın kayıp Cennet ve mareşal onun
Frankenstein eserlerin karşılaştırmasını
yaptım makalenin sonuç bölümü Ben
kesmişim ve dostluk son ders yani not
almaya gitmiyoruz oraya onun arkasında
yazmışım benim için çok güzeldi yani beş
sene boyunca inanılmaz güzel hocalardan
inanılmaz güzel dersler aldım çok şeyler
öğrendim Fakat şu elimdeki Naughty 22
Mayıs 2014'te yazılmış salam üniversite
hayatında aldım en güzel derste ve
kariyerimi de bu şekilde planlama vesile
oldu
Bunun bir benzerini ben sizlere
yazdırmak istiyorum Eğer elin önünüzde
bir kağıt kalem varsa rica edeceğim
Yazın telefonunuz daysan telefonunuzdan
atalım ve ve zorlandığını zamanlarda
Umarım bulunduğu açık okursunuz bir
üniversitede e Ya ben bir hoca değilim
ancak insani olarak Aynı düzlemde
olduğumuzu düşünüyorum Elçin hocaydı
bana bunu yazmam bize bunu yazdıran
ders değil hayata dair sizin yaşamamızı
istediğim notlardan biri şöyle 8 tane
madde yazdım Eğer 3 beğenmezseniz yazın
isterim ben de belki Bundan yıllar
yıllar sonra çıkarıp ya ne kadar güzel
bir şey demiş adımı unutsanız bile olur
ama söyleyeceğim maddeler size belki de
motivasyon sağlar çünkü ben hala yeni
yıl olmuş 2021 2014'ten kalan notumu
saklıyorum özellikle cüzdanında
saklıyorum ve canım sıkıldıkça ona
bakıyorum eder soluyorum üniversitenin
dersi buydu Benim için o Umarım Sizlerde
Şimdi not alıyorsunuz Hazırsanız madde
bir ile başlıyorum ben okuyacağım zaten
kaydediliyor burada video sanırım
Sonradan da eğer yetişemez Seni
tekrardan
izleyip not alabilirsiniz
bu
maddedir bir üniversitede sevdiğim
bölümü okumaya çabalayacağım Ama
madde-2 sevdiğim işi yapmayı deneyeceğim
e
madde 3 kendime bir hobi ediceğime ne
kadar zor olduğunu biliyorum
yapabilirsiniz madde dört yılda en az
bir kere tiyatroya gideceğim eve bir
filmi sinemada izleyeceğim e madde 52
kitapları okuyacağıma madde 6 gerçek
aşkı yaşamaya ve ona sahip çıkmaya
çalışacağım a 7 bir gün iyi bir anne ya
da baba olacağıma ve madde sekiz son
olarak kötü olmak çok kolay K Nidem
Dönmeyen başkalarına ve en önemlisi
Kendine saygısı olan bir birey olacağıma
söz veriyorum
Altına da 8temmuz 2021 yazarsınız Umarım
bu maddelerin hepsini yapmak sizlere
nasip olur umarım çok çok iyi insan Çok
teşekkür ederim
[Müzik]